but you are about to see is inspired by
true events
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey people welcome to the latest episode
of the 13 o'clock podcast what's up
we're back yeah and we're gonna do like
another horror kind of themed thing cuz
I said a few shows ago that I wanted to
get back to doing that so we're gonna do
kind of movies horror movies based on
real cases but not not the most obvious
one I wanted to pick some ones that were
kind of off-the-wall awful a little
newer I think it's okay yeah yeah it's
not like you don't have evil yeah most
of them are newer okay and but before we
do that let's do our regular kind of
shoutouts first want to give a you know
our regular shadow tube projects
entertainment network whose the audio
version of our podcast they have a
patreon at patreon.com slash project
Antonette if you want to go and give
them a buck or two and support there's
probably I think there's 14 podcasts on
the network now right and they've been
getting a lot of a lot more listeners in
the past couple of months so that's
pretty cool and also get another plug
for my new book yeah yes the unseen hand
a new exploration of poltergeist
phenomena and it's out in all three
formats print ebook and audiobook yeah
we don't have any data on the sales for
the e-book with a print book yet but
data came back for the audiobooks and
hey thank you guys
boy it did really well in its first week
I know I was very surprised at how many
sold in the first couple weeks I had it
up there yeah and that was without any
promotion yeah you've done two shows
you've been a guest on what was it in
today's radio yeah everybody go and
listen to me I was on end of days radio
and I've done the Jim Harold show yeah
and yeah and also this coming Wednesday
which is a 26 I think is the 26 I'm on
beyond the darkness radio yeah and I'm
on there about an hour talking about
poltergeists and stuff like that in
general
yeah but then the new poltergeist book
is doing seemingly very well yeah you
know just in the first week so about 11
copies as far as we know of just
audiobook yes without any promotion yeah
that's good that's before that was
for the shows that you did went up yeah
to promote it so there's only one of
them is up at this at this job
so that's any if that was any of our
listeners it was just uh we'd like to
thank you yes thank you very much
yeah you guys will love the book go
ahead and pick up a copy yeah it's a
it's good if you're into poltergeist
type activity and I think that's that's
pretty much all the housekeeping you had
to do right yeah we can get into story
all right so let's kind of get into the
story and like I said we're doing horror
movies based on true stories yeah now
obviously a lot of people know you know
stuff like psycho and the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre which were based on loosely
based on Ed Gein Henry portrait of
serial killer based on what the hell was
that Henry Lee Lucas Lucas the serial
killer the entity based on the case of
Doris Bither we even do a show actually
where our first show was partially about
that yeah Exorcist Exorcism of Emily
Rose
you know that was the Roland doe case
was the Exorcist and Annalise Michelle
or McHale was Exorcism of Emily Rose but
the both of them are in my book and you
know Amityville Horror obviously we did
a show about that too yeah but I kind of
picked some ones that were newer but
also maybe weren't as well-known that
they were actually sort of based on true
stories and the first one I wanted to
talk about the movie came out in 2012
and it's called the possession now for
all you Walking Dead fans out there
which we count ourselves among the the
main character is played by a Jeffrey
Dean Morgan and it's actually very funny
I honestly that's the guy who plays the
guy who plays Nick Indiana so um it was
actually pretty funny like watching the
movie because I'm so used to seeing him
out walking dead and I don't really you
know I don't see a lot of other movies
or TV shows so that's pretty much the
main thing I've seen him on so it's very
funny to like see him playing so what
keeps his honorable person what case is
the position based on now the possession
the movie is actually pretty decent like
I you know I wasn't expecting that much
but actually I was pretty good but it's
based on the supposedly real case the
infamous case of the
Haunted Dybbuk box so the Dybbuk box
okay here we go
yes okay now that was that what you know
what the I gotta give you credit I gotta
give him credit though the Dybbuk box
was an awesome story on Superman I first
saw it on what was it super yeah that
was an awesome story it is a very good
story and kind of an original story now
the movie the possession it does keep
the central conceit of the Haunted
Dybbuk box which has like a demonic
spirit inside of it you know and it
keeps the the thing where it was bought
at a at a yard sale but other than that
it's a pretty standard possession story
it's like pretty much it's bought at the
box has bought at a yard sale you know
the daughter is kind of attracted to it
and wants it and she figures out how to
open it and subsequently becomes
possessed by this demon and then you
know the dad has to go to Brooklyn and
find like a like a rabbi or something
like that to exorcise in case you don't
know wouldn't what a dybbuk box is it's
a box and Jewish mystics claim to use
these boxes to store demons inside them
are you you entrap well they trap them
in the trap and almost comically you
trap a genie in a bottle yeah and it's
just like a little wooden box that has
some relics in it that help hold it in
there right that's what a dybbuk box is
so good maybe there may be people in the
audience that don't know what a dybbuk
spire well I was gonna I was gonna say I
was just talking about the movie and
then I was gonna talk about the actual
case now some of you may have seen the
case on paranormal witness now whether
this case is completely true or not not
really sure maybe this guy was just a
marketing genius and like know how to
take something you know like an eBay
listing and turn it into like a
lucrative movie yeah career or something
like that but basically this is how the
story goes there's a guy named Kevin
Mannis right and he was apparently he
owned a little antique shop or something
like that and he sometimes bought stuff
at estate sales and whatnot so he was at
this estate sale in 2003 and he bought
this wine cab
that was yeah I don't think he bought it
on purpose but it just kind of came with
a bunch of stuff in the estate sale or
whatever now the when he was purchasing
it evidently
the woman who he was buying it from he
said that it the box had belonged to her
grandmother who had survived the
Holocaust right and she had bought the
box in Spain and she brought it over
here when she immigrated after the the
granddaughter told him that he was like
oh well you can keep it you can have it
back because the grandmother had died
that's right that was the estate sale
they were selling all her stuff and the
granddaughter insisted no you paid for
it you take it we don't want it anymore
right you know according to this Kevin
guy he's like okay whatever so I'll take
it with me okay so he figured out how to
open the box which apparently it it was
pretty well made like I think in the
movie they kind of had it where it was
like a seeker like he couldn't figure
out how to open it really but it sort of
opened yeah on its own or a little
padlock I think pretty much yeah and he
said now if when you open one door like
the other one and like a little drawer
open so it kind of had like a mechanism
in there that sort of open it but I
don't think it was like secretly like
you weren't supposed to open it or
anything like that but he says he gets
it back to his shop and he opens it and
he finds two pennies from the 1920s two
locks of hair like one lock blonde and
one lock brown and they were like bound
up with a cord and he also found a
little statue that had this Hebrew word
Shalom in it and a little wine goblet
dried rosebud and a single candle holder
with little octopus shaped legs right he
claims that as soon as the box was in
his shop he started having like almost
kind of like poltergeist type activity
happening in the store now I don't know
like he didn't really see I think he saw
like figures and stuff like that but his
employee that had been there for two
years
she said that there
someone in the basement all the
lightbulbs have broken like all the
lights went out like all this really
weird [ __ ] went on and then for some
reason even though like this is why I'm
not sure I entirely by the guys okay but
he's like so all this weird [ __ ] is
happening around this box and he says I
know what I'll do I'm gonna refinish it
and then I'm gonna give it to my mom for
her birthday right okay which is what
you do when there's a I don't think I
mean well at first like you wouldn't
really assess cuz he bought a bunch of
other stuff too like any estate so maybe
you wouldn't like okay so maybe he
didn't make the connection alright but
so he refinishes he gives it to his mom
now on the same day that he gives it to
his mom for her birthday present his mom
has a stroke right now I think later she
was alright like she kind of regained
some of her speech and stuff like that
but while she was in her while she was
in the hospital and stuff like that
apparently she tried to spell out the
words hate to gift at him like she
didn't want it or anything like that now
so after all this stuff ended up
happening Kevin man is he puts the
Dybbuk box up on ebay because he said
you know I tried to he he gave it to
like his brother and his wife and kept
it at their house for three days and
they gave it back and you know he put at
his sister's house and she kept it for a
few days and gave it back they all
complained about they said the box
either smelled like jasmine or like cat
urine and sometimes it would be found
open when no one had touched it yeah and
just like weird [ __ ] like bad luck type
stuff was happening evidently he tried
to sell it and he sold it to a couple
from from his store like after his mom
had had her stroke and the people that
had bought it like brought it back a
couple days later they left it like in
front of the store with a note but it
had some kind of darkness and they
didn't want it right yeah so then he
puts it up on eBay and the next person
to buy it was actually like I think was
a university student yeah and you know
cuz like you do you're cruising eBay and
you're like oh
look it's a haunted Jewish wine cabinet
yeah I want in the transaction a wine
cab yeah that's what it was
every dry made us and so this university
student bought the Dybbuk box and I must
say I must say before you before you
continue yeah this story of the Dybbuk
box being sold on eBay has caused other
Dybbuk boxes yeah there's time your
honor and you know haunted dolls there's
a whole industry of selling haunted crap
on eBay
my favorite one was the ghost in the jar
yeah my advice is people uh don't don't
fall for it I can take anything
seriously I'm not saying don't sell that
kind of stuff go to those you know it if
you go for it yeah just don't buy that
guy well I wouldn't but I wouldn't buy
it you know unless you liked it the
novelty of yeah cuz the chances are
chances are you're being taken ya say
that there isn't I would buy it if I
needed a wine cabinet and if I thought
it was pretty and if it was like 10
bucks and if it came with a cool story
yeah be any more than like 20 bucks that
would be the most I'm not paying like to
it cuz I think that the university
student I think he ended up paying quite
a bit for it any like oh it was 80 bucks
or is he on auction didn't it go crazy
on it maybe it was 207 yeah like 200
something yeah I have to go back and
look been a long time but I was looking
at it I remember in the show yeah when I
was when I watch the documentary I saw
the price that they showed at least on
the screen I'm going why would a college
student pay that much money for that
wooden box yeah why would you know it's
like you'd have to be pretty surely
you'd have to be a believer yeah it was
some kind of lark that's like hey we're
gonna get a Jewish demon this will be
rad yeah but yeah so this university
soon boys will be boys yeah I guess and
he kind of said the same thing he said
it smelled like cat pee that he found it
open all the time
all the lights went out in his apartment
and all his hair started to fall out he
like he kept a blog I guess I'm not sure
how long he kept it um he actually ended
up writing like from all his blog posts
I think he end up writing a book called
the Dybbuk box which about his
experience
with it now he eventually sold it to a
friend of his or a guy that had been
following his blogs and was interested
in the box and so this other guy bought
a Jason Haxton I think his name was and
he bought it and he evidently I don't
think anything bad happened to that guy
but he took it to a bunch of rabbis and
was like you know how do we put the
Dybbuk back in the box and like seal it
back in there and stuff and evidently
that whatever they did to it worked
because I and then this this Jason
person took it to a secured location
which he didn't tell anybody about and
hid it yeah so you gotta watch his
Jewish guys man they make DivX big
McDivitt boxes they make golems they can
make all kinds of stuff well the thing
it okay now now here's the thing is is
it like is there a dybbuk in your house
and then you're just like what we're
gonna put it in the box and so we can't
get out no guys stop messing around got
that or the the story behind it was is
that there was one of the family members
if I recall one of the family members
was a medium whose doing seances yeah oh
right yeah okay yeah they put a dybbuk
into the box Deering for some reason
like he do it was during some seances
that they were doing evidently maybe
somebody had a problem with a demon okay
so you know and they had to find a place
to put in they have to figure out what
to do with this box and it got passed
down through some family members that
that's what that's how I recall the
story yeah it's not really important
personally I don't believe a story it's
a good it's a good story I don't really
believe this story but we got to tell it
because yes sorry it's never Fox sure
it's a good story and actually like I
said the possession I wasn't expecting
much and and the story and the way they
do it in the movie there's nothing about
the eBay thing there's nothing about you
know it going to successive people they
did use the box and the demon being
trapped in the box but other than that
it's pretty much a standard possession
story but for all that it's actually
pretty good I don't know another thing
that makes the story cool is that it's
Jewish
well yeah you don't see a lot of see
Jewish mythology no use movies got Irish
guys with talking to ghosts yeah German
guys you know with poltergeists and
ghosts you never really hear about
Jewish guys just golems yeah
golem see I mean I think that gosh the
last movie they made about a golem was
when I remember the old silent they need
to bring that back
they really do cuz that's a rad idea
yeah golems and DivX yeah keep it keep
that in mind Hollywood executives
there's like a fresh angle for some
horror movies there you haven't really
been explored very much but yeah that's
you know like I said the whole the whole
ethnic angle coming with a whole lot I
mean they're kind of they pretty much
acts sort of like regular white people
Damon's dog demons are Jewish yeah think
about it fits like a demons a demon if
you're talking about Old Testament those
this you know that's Jewish stuff yeah
that's true all genes all teams are Jews
yeah I guess you got a point there
according to the Old Testament yeah all
right so you know possession like if you
like possession movies I would recommend
it okay now speaking of possession
here's another one now the thing they
did with this particular movie was they
kind of made it into sort of like a
possession movie even though the
original case wasn't really like that
which I guess is kind of what they did
with the last case but so okay in 2014 a
movie came out called the quiet ones now
it was actually made by hammer studios
yes that hammer yeah which the Peter
Cushing the Peter Cushing and
Christopher lazybones yeah say you were
watching the other day what was that
movie we were watching at the Earth's
core of the Earth's core on the new
mystery second a ship they're not been
zoomed in on Peter Cushing's face and I
said Jenny I want those cheekbones for
real doc I had the greatest show so I
want this cheekbones Jenny goes this is
genetics has the best skull battery hell
is back teeth pulled out I guess so yeah
they're so sunken eyes
but yes so evidently like a few years
back
hammer Studios has been trying to kind
of make a comeback now the first movie
they started out with was they made kind
of a they made a English / American
remake of the very popular Swedish
vampire movie Let The Right One In just
called let man which was actually pretty
decent I mean the original Swedish ones
a lot better but and they actually did
they actually made the woman in black
with Daniel Radcliffe who played Harry
Potter obviously but the quiet ones was
kind of the third when it came out now
the quiet ones it tells the story about
there's like a universities at Oxford
University professor and he believes
that all this kind of possession jazz
and all that kind of stuff we're not too
deep with this what did we actually
finish the Dybbuk story what not well
yeah I said yeah so the guy hit it and
that's pretty much like oh yeah what you
like show goddamnit what are you saying
useful he's full of beans today I don't
really know what his problem we would
need to be we wouldn't be able to be in
the same room you'd have to go through
skunk ape for nothing that's true that
out that's actually true Appalachian we
got this we had to a show about the
Florida skunk ape yeah we all do yeah of
course we've never seen it no unless it
really is you which I can respect
sometimes we have to track down where
that story came from yeah we might be
able to find the person that first
reported it that wore the suit and why
you don't know maybe that was a hoax
based on a real real thing yeah real
report and we don't know you know we
have research that yeah yeah yeah we'll
get to that that's that's a future show
yeah okay so our ethnic story Florida
skunk ape all right so the quiet ones
told a story about an oxford university
professor who believed that this ball
does possession
as was kind of which action was kind of
the premise of my book that is actually
caused by like psychokinesis and that
and that the psychokinesis could somehow
be drawn out of the person and it would
cure them or something like that
so so okay so the doctor has this girl
that he takes out of a mental asylum and
he has like all his little students and
stuff like that and they have all these
little sessions with this girl where
they're trying to draw out it's kind of
like possession but not like they're
trying to draw out whatever it is that's
causing her to have all this weird
behavior and how to draw it and they're
trying to but well with like seance II
type sessions and stuff like that all
right
yeah that reminds me of what's that the
claims and during the satanic panic the
cha cha child abuse where you get a
child they do rituals with them and then
it summons demons yeah it's almost kind
of like the same theme yeah you get a
kid you do this with these you know like
a disturbed person in this case and you
do all these weird seance II stuff to
draw out the psychic abilities out of
them the same story ya told in a
different way I mean in the movie this
guy was actually trying he was trying to
cure her I guess but he was also trying
to prove his theory that the the
supernatural of the paranormal wasn't
really real per se but it was just
caused by this sort of telekinetic
ability that could be drawn out they
were trying to put it inside this doll
for some reason I don't really know why
that's what I think it is this yeah yeah
that's what I mean that was kind of the
same theme as my as my book or these
kinds of it yeah and um you know I don't
I'm not gonna spoil anything like that
now the quiet ones not super well
received
seemed like I I mean I liked the woman
in black a lot of people didn't it was
kind of but but this one seemed a lot
more polarizing a lot of people didn't
like it because it seemed like it was
pretty much all jumpscares
um you know and it just didn't seem like
I don't know the the premise to me
seemed kind of dumb but what's funny is
that how Jeff's cares no longer work
they don't work well and this and the
shitty thing to about this one is that
almost all the jump scares were fake
jump scares like it was always like oh
I'm just your friend right now it's like
that's so lame that is searching
they don't work easy no everybody's just
like oh oh okay work in a theater no no
well everyone jumps but then they just
laugh like a lame rule again yeah I
guess you have to have become on edge to
get the job yeah
well yeah but see they do that in movies
it's like oh it's but you know they're
gonna do it because it's super quiet it
gets super quiet and you're like oh it's
gonna be loud in a second right you know
what I mean but um so okay as weird as
the premise is this was actually based
on a real thing and the real thing that
it was based on was called the Filip
experiment now this happened in the 70s
from night in 1972 and it should be
noted too that the movie the quiet ones
was actually they made it it was set in
1974 so even though it's not exactly
like the actual experiment they did set
it in that time period and made it look
like it was a movie from that time
period but what the Filip experiment was
it wasn't so much about well I guess it
kinda was about telekinesis but they
were it was a group of pair of
psychologists or psychologists and there
was a mathematician and a couple other
people sociology student and they were
trying to see if they could essentially
make a spirit like just through the
force of their will like like cause the
spirit to manifest is basically what
they were trying to do so what they did
was they got together and they invented
a fictitious dead person they gave him a
they gave him a name his name is Philip
Aylesford they gave him an entire
history like how he died and stuff like
that he was born in 1624 and England
he'd been in the English Civil War you
know he was married to a woman named
Dorothea like he fell in love with a
gypsy girl she died she got burned at
the stake I think because if she had
accused of witchcraft or something and
then he killed himself at the age of 30
now they had so what they would do was
they would have like essentially seance
sessions where they would they had like
draw they would draw pictures of the guy
they would like have pictures of castles
like one he would have lived in and
stuff
that and they were basically trying to
concentrate and see if they could get
this personality to manifest just from
them because they wanted to prove that
you know all these quote-unquote spirits
that were coming through through seances
and stuff like that were actually just
bull driven people yeah the living
people participating okay now while the
controls for the Filip experiment have
been criticized for not being super
stringent which a lot of these are kind
of experiments or not they did get some
kind of interesting results in the fact
that you know they got the table to move
like the table would rise up and the
table apparently chased him around the
room a couple of times yeah and they did
get a spirit quote-unquote sort of
nothing nothing visual like manifested I
guess but they did get something to
manifest that could answer their
questions like with knocking and things
like that now interestingly it could
only answer questions that they knew the
answers to because they were the ones
that came up with the dude so they said
that sometimes it could answer questions
from the time period that he supposedly
lived in but they think that that was
you know just from historical general
historical knowledge that the people
knew just kind of coming out so they did
them for a few years now they've they've
tried to repeat them later on with mixed
results but the thing about it is that
there was nothing particularly sinister
about it other than people that are
believers in the paranormal and will say
oh well it really was a ghost and he was
or a demon and he was just [ __ ] with
you because you guys were having a
seance and like playing with the
paranormal so a little demon decided he
was gonna play a trick on you and come
and be your person you would have a
rabbit hole yeah yeah but like I said
you know there's no way to prove that
you know yeah so like like I said if
anything did happen they did kind of
demonstrate yeah this stuff was all just
from the living people that participated
but like I said there was nothing about
possession there was nothing about there
was nothing really
you know bad or evil or anything nothing
bad happened you know what I mean it was
just like a bunch of people interested
in that type of thing that we're seeing
if they could come up with a ghost and
apparently they did it I guess
although like I said they have been
criticized that the controls were not
super stringent but they were more
stringent than the school experiment
yeah we did a show about that tear you
know how we feel about that if so you
know the quiet ones like I I feel like I
what like I love Hammer movies and I
liked the woman in black and stuff like
that quiet ones it's kind of I didn't
live really like and all that much
however there actually was another movie
made in 2012 and it was called the
apparition and it was much closer I mean
it's still a horror movie but it was
much closer to the actual Philip
experiment Protocol like it didn't have
the thing about the disturbed girl and
the thing with the doll and all that
kind of stuff now the interesting thing
about the apparition which I had
actually never even heard of I just kind
of saw a lot of research in the other
movies but it apparently got the worst
horror movie of 2012 you know name
because I'm able to see this one
evidently yeah this one I have not seen
but this one is wonder what made this
one so bad yeah see I don't know but is
this one actually was almost exactly
like they had an experiment it was
called the Charles experiment in the
apparition and it happens in 1973 right
about the time that the actual Philip
experiment was taking place so it was
kind of the same thing where they wanted
to do a period piece about this
particular thing but apparently you know
like I said people didn't love the quiet
ones but apparently this one is waste
shittier even though it's much closer
that means I got to see it much closer
to the actual so I guess we'll see the
thing is is it shitty in the sense that
it's like hilariously shitty or is it
just shitty in the sense that it's just
boring because there's a big decision
didn't live up to the expectations of
the audience maybe you know maybe they
wanted it to be a have a bunch of jump
scares and you know and they wanted it
to support an idea that it did not
support in other words maybe yeah
I don't know yeah I don't know I got it
I got to stop talking about it because I
haven't seen it I would kind of be
interested to see it
only has a 3% rating on Rotten Tomatoes
I gotta see it yeah I gotta see it I
kind of want to see it I I kind of have
the feeling though just like from
reading about it cuz like I said I
haven't seen it just from reading about
it it sounds like it would just be
boring
oh we're just like like a generic so
it's boring bad not star crash bad yeah
star crash is a terrible movie yeah but
you laughed the whole way do it
see that's what I mean tonight and I
feel like they don't really make a lot
of movies like star crash or like movies
like that anymore that that they
actually kind of intended to be good but
we're actually so sucky that they
actually kind of come will come around
and become awesome again because they're
so inept yeah we still haven't figured
out the plot to start crash I still do
not know what's going on I don't know
what's happening I don't know what's
going on I don't know what's going on
with Marjoe Gortner x' hair and his
weird ass high facial expressions
yeah well oh I guess I just answered my
own question but yeah we've thought I've
seen on MST I've seen it really I have
no idea what's good does it not watch
star crash treat yourself you can
probably see that for free on YouTube
yeah you can probably find it somewhere
was an Italian Star Wars ripoff
essentially although he says it wasn't a
Star Wars ripoff paddleball yeah it was
hilarious I don't believe it yeah it was
very funny okay so we're at the halfway
point and when we come back I'm gonna
talk about two more really depressing
cases I don't know why I always end with
the depressing stuff that's what we're
gonna so uh we'll do two more movies
when we get back and we'll be back in
just a few minutes how do people who
make stuff up for a living make stuff up
New York Times best seller Jonathan
Mayberry told us Oprah's Book Club
favorite sue Miller told us do you take
a character and make some bad things
happen hope we have time to do
we colored them just like at a cocktail
party except through your headphones
join us every Thursday for the liar's
club odd cat a slightly unhinged podcast
where storytellers interview other
storytellers available on project
entertainment network iTunes and
everywhere podcasts are heard subculture
corsets and clothing is our favorite
store for unusual clothing shoes and
accessories they offer a wide selection
of men's and women's clothing at great
prices
soap culture also offers the cool
selection of shoes and accessories
steampunk gothic apparel retro corsets
and so much more at subculture corsets
and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets calm that's
subculture corsets calm make sure you
use the discount code 13 o'clock for a
10% discount subculture corsets calm or
visit their store in Jacksonville
Florida just off i-95
[Music]
mr. Frank the song is the showcase
podcast of the bizarro fiction genre and
goes you're right weird and read weird
are gonna love so join us here every
Monday presented exclusively by the
project
[Music]
[Music]
okay and we're back and we're gonna talk
about two more horror movies that were
based on real cases this is going fast I
can't believe this is going this fast
yeah I know right yeah all right all
right so the next time I want to talk
about and this is probably the most
[ __ ] up one there was a movie it came
out in 2007 and it was called the girl
next door oh this one yeah now it was
actually based on a 1989 novel by a Jack
ketchum who is actually one of my
favorite like more modern horror writers
but he writes some pretty [ __ ] up [ __ ]
yeah this one's a bummer this was kind
of a bummer yeah well this is why we
didn't do some last last right you know
what I mean but okay interestingly so
the girl next door that's the one I've
seen there was actually another movie
that came out it was made in 2007 but
didn't get a theatrical release because
of some kind of problem with the
distributor but it premiered on Showtime
in 2008 and that was called an American
crime and that's actually more directly
based on the case that the girl next
door is also based on the girl next door
is kind of fictionalized but not much I
have to say and and the real case is
disturbing but in the movie the girl
next door it's basically it said in the
50s there's this woman named Aunt Ruth
and these two girls their sisters their
parents died and she's sent to live with
the aunt now I don't remember if the
aunts actually related or if they just
call her that
like maybe she's just a friend of the
family or something like that I don't
know but they they go and live with her
and for some reason Aunt Ruth gets this
be up her ass that the older daughter is
like a filthy [ __ ] or something like
that and starts abusing her which would
be bad enough but she also gets all the
neighborhood kids in on the act right
now
I gotta say the book by Jack Ketchum
that is one of the most disturbing
things I've ever read and actually the
first time I read it I didn't know that
it was based on a real case right you
know and then when you see the movie
like the movie kind of toned it down a
little bit cuz you know they couldn't
show some of the stuff could I guess I
would have been too but but the book
like that definitely I needed a
we shower after that it was awful and I
hate to tell you that it's based on a
real case and the real case was the
murder of Sylvia Lake ins and this
happened in 1965 in Indiana
now in the movie the two sisters that go
to stay with the woman their parents die
but in real life her pet their parents
were not dead their parents actually
were carnival workers and they traveled
around a lot and they didn't have a lot
of money and so what they would do is
they would leave their kids with various
relatives and friends of the family and
stuff like that for periods of time
while they were out traveling around
with the carnival right the the older
sister was Sylvia likens she was 16 at
the time and she had a younger sister
named Jenny who was 15 who had polio now
they had other kids but I don't really
know where the other kids were cuz I
think they had like three other kids so
Sylvia and Jenny were sent to live with
this woman named Gertrude baños bana
chef ski and she was not related to them
she was actually the mother of a friend
of theirs named Paula and I guess you
know when when the girl's parents were
going out on their latest you know
carnival thing or whatever they were
like hey want to board our daughters for
20 bucks a week or whatever it was and
and apparently they weren't too picky
about you know right so they said they
met him at church or something like that
and they said that you know their friend
paula was 17 and this was her mom and
this woman Gertrude she already had she
had six kids I think and she was a
single mother like her boyfriend her
husband had taken off which probably
won't surprise you when you find out
what happened but okay so the first
thing I'd not sure how long these two
girls lived there before the [ __ ]
started hitting the fan but apparently
what triggered it was that the dad who
was supposed to be paying Gertrude 20
dollars a week to look after his
daughters was late with one payment so
since the day
was not there Gertrude figured well I'm
gonna beat the hell out of the girls
like his punishment cuz their dad's a
bum or something like that apparently
what happened after that was that a
letter came with the payment from the
dad you know saying oh sorry it's late
and blah blah blah
now Gertrude took this letter and she
threw it away so she could continue like
abusing the girls now this is like
really home and I can't really
understand what this woman's mindset was
like I don't know if she beat her other
kids cuz she had a bunch that one was
like a baby one was like 1 year old or
something like that when this should
happen this was in 1965 I think and she
was able to get her kids and some of the
neighbor kids in on this [ __ ] now the
first thing that happened like I said
she would beat the kids with a belt
Sylvia more than Jenny I mean Jenny had
polio she was disabled so I don't think
she got it quite as bad but for some
reason Gertrude got it into her head
that Sylvia was a [ __ ] and that she was
pregnant and all this other stuff which
is weird because her own daughter Paula
who was 17 was actually pregnant she had
gotten pregnant with her girlfriend with
her boyfriend rather yeah without a
turkey baster but you know what I mean
so Paula actually kicked Sylvia in the
vagina and accused her of being pregnant
which you know she couldn't have been
because I think in the in the autopsy
they determined that she was a virgin
but also she got her Gertrude
got her kids to push Sylvia down the
stairs and then she got one of the
because some of her her daughters were
teenagers and one of them had a
boyfriend and she got the boyfriend in
on it and a bunch of like little
neighbor kids that were like 9 and 10
years old right like four or five of
them they would they kind of kept her
down in the basement
Gertrude wouldn't feed her she was like
starving she wouldn't give her any water
you know which basically kept her tied
up down there beat her with belts they
would put cigarettes out on her poor boy
water on her and then pour salt on the
wounds yeah they would make her eat her
own [ __ ] yeah they would take like poop
out of the baby's diaper and make her
eat it
yeah and tied up and all this was it she
was like tied up down a basement you
know basically they they would make her
I don't think she didn't get raped in
the movie she did yeah but um you know
in the autopsy they determined that she
probably had been but what they would do
is they would make her take her clothes
off and then stick a coke bottle up her
vagina yeah and while they were like
watching and stuff yeah like they would
make her do that at one point Gertrude
hit the kid in the face so hard that she
broke her own wrist like hey that's how
hard how long did this go on for this
was like you know I don't really know it
was like a few weeks a few months
something like that it wasn't a super
long time not really stated no cuz
they're not sure what it would Death
would they knew when she died yeah they
don't know when the abuse story right
right yeah she also got the you know
Sylvia's younger sister Jenny the the
one with polio she got her to hit the
girl like her she said you know she
yeah yeah or she said she yeah she would
do horrible things her and stuff like
that now it kind of sucked because
Silvia and Jenny they really didn't have
any way to contact their parents I mean
their parents were on the road there
were carnival people they couldn't
reunited em cell phones obviously in
1965 so they couldn't just call their
mom and be like hey this woman is crazy
now they had another sister named Diana
and what ended up happening was that
Diana found out that maybe something
sketchy was going on so she went to the
house and asked to see Silvia and Jenny
but Gertrude who Diana didn't know
Gertrude answered the door and said oh
just you know Sylvia is not here she
wouldn't let her in the house Sylvie's
not here she ran away
damn so she was like telling people that
she ran away right and basically told
her get off my property blah blah now a
neighbor did report Gertrude at some
point cuz they thought something was
nobody knew
what was going on exactly right because
it all took place in the house like the
neighbor kids would come over and you
know Gertrude would be like hey let's go
down to the basement and stick
cigarettes you like put cigarettes out
on this board or all and all this other
stuff and you know so people thought
something weird was going on so they did
she did get reported but like a nurse
came to the house like to see what was
going on I guess it was like the 1965
version of Child Protective Services or
whatever but she didn't look in the
basement and again Gertrude said oh well
what happened was Sylvia she like she
just ran away and she's went off and
became a prostitute or something like
that like she that's what she was
telling people that this teenage girl
she was like tied up in the basement the
whole time for a while Sylvia had gone
to school but then um Gertrude wouldn't
let her go anymore because I guess she
was afraid she was gonna narc on her or
something like that and um but like a
few days before she died were like a few
of like a couple weeks before she died
Gertrude got the idea to burn or carve
the words I'm a prostitute and proud of
it on Sylvia's abdomen with a hot needle
and she got one of her little kids like
to heat the needle up weird and then she
started burning it they know this
happened mm-hmm
this almost sounds too fantastical good
to be true no it is it's actually still
considered like the worst crime ever
perpetrated in Indiana hmm and they even
like even what made her think she was
gonna get away with this
see I had no idea the woman was she must
be she must been schizophrenic yes I
mean she obviously had some problems
yeah the only explain she's issues and
the creepy thing to me and her
psychopathy and I think the creepy thing
too she was she to get away with this
she would have had to have killed the
girl yeah and then they still would have
known that she killed her yeah as a kid
would it did the parents are coming back
yeah what the hell was she thinking I
don't know that's what I mean it's like
she's just really really warped I mean
you know and she would like she wanted
to like like burn an s into her skin
like with an iron poker and stuff like
that yeah how is she gonna explain this
to the parents right
well Dibble here's what she was here was
her plan she actually forced Sylvia to
write a note to her parents yeah that
said that she was running away right and
the the story that Gertrude concocted
was that Sylvia had turned to
prostitution and that she had had sex
with all these boys or promised she was
going to have sex with all these boys
for money and they came to the house and
took her or she ran away with them and
they dragged her trying to kill her so
yeah because Gertrude basically was like
after she had been so beat up and
everything like that and after you know
people had come
checking she told some of some of the
kids like take her out in the woods and
leave her to die right yeah so that's
what she was gonna do and she was gonna
make it look like she had just run away
with these kids need help
see that's the creepiest aspect of its
in right now she got like a bunch of her
kids and some of them are girls like
teenage girls and like [ __ ] like that
and some of them were little like some
like 10 years old at the time and stuff
like that how could she keep all those
kids silent yes she's young yeah I mean
crazy now okay and the sad part too is
that better than yeah October 25th 1965
and Sylvia actually tried to escape
because she heard Gertrude talking about
dragging her out to the forest leaving
her there yeah so she tried to get out
but Gertrude caught her when she was
trying to get out the front door and so
she tied her back in the basement
now the next the day after that Sylvia
died her body just couldn't take it
anymore she was malnourished she was
dehydrated she bit through her own she
bit through her own lips yeah yeah you
think they can they can look at it yeah
it's a horrible horrible horrible case
and basically and it sucks too because
like a lot of like Gertrude was
obviously tried but she only got Julia
20 years and
at least she didn't really have any she
said she didn't remember why she did it
or anything like that she seemed like a
[ __ ] nutcase
and um Paula the 17 year old daughter
she went to prison but got let out kind
of early she got paroled kind of early
and you know some of the younger kids
like Gertrude son John when he was 13
and you know they went to prison but not
for very long and I think the argument
and some of the kids I think you know
the ones that were kind of 10 and stuff
like that they thought they were too
young so they didn't bother prosecuting
them but it's just the weird thing to
like I said a lot of them went free some
of them changed their names later not
surprisingly um the weird thing too is
that a lot of them died young hmm which
I thought was kind of strange when I was
like when I was researching what
happened to all the people like I said a
lot of them changed their names and
stuff like that but you know a lot of
them died like in their 50s one although
one of them I think I think it was John
who was 13 year old who was 13 at the
time of the crime I think he died of
cancer when he was only 21 now what did
the victim actually die of what was the
cause of death I said that already
Baldur just his malnourishment
dehydration plus she had been burnt she
had like a large under damage everything
all this pot yeah she had a lot of nerve
damage from a you know from the burning
per day pour boiling water on her and
then broke salt in it and stuff like
that they said when they found they said
like her vagina was basically swollen
shut
like all the stuff yet yeah so um it's a
bummer man it is a box a [ __ ] bummer
and we're over time on this case well a
little bit yeah but yeah if you want to
see the girl next door it's actually a
very good movie it's it's very
disturbing the book is very disturbing I
haven't seen an American crime I
probably that one is actually directly
based on it with everybody with the same
names and everything the girl next door
is fictionalized but it's pretty much a
very similar story to what actually
happened fucked-up [ __ ] I don't
understand people like I said this
happened 1965 so look it up Sylvia
likens it's really not pleasant don't
you live in the water yeah yeah I don't
know what the problem
okay so that was kind of a bummer so
let's um I know this is gonna sound
funny but it's like let's lighten it up
a little bit and talk about suicide 13
o'clock well actually it is this is a
little bit more cheerful than that
because it's like suicide at least
you're only hurting yourself you're not
hurting other people you know all right
so okay the movie were talking about
came out in 2016 and it was called the
Forrest said about that Japanese suicide
yes it is that's what it's based on so
apparently the movie was all right we
had a fan request we did yet but and
actually that's what gave me the idea to
do this show because I didn't I was like
well I don't know if I want to do it was
offhand but there's the here's your
suicide forest yeah I didn't want to do
like an entire show on that because I
said oh I don't know if I could talk
about that for an hour there's not a lot
to it
but but it reminded me I said oh they
made that movie I was like oh let's do
like a bunch of movies that were based
on real things so yeah there was a movie
called the force that came out in 2016
now in the movie you know a girl she
figures out their sister has gone into
the suicide forest and she goes to Japan
to look for and stuff like that now in
the movie it turned out they're like
demons in there and [ __ ] like that you
know movies okay it's not great it's
good you know it's kind of just a blah
whatever but it is based on a real place
and this real place improve most people
in perturbance japanese suicide for is
called a hokey Kihara
sometimes cokie Gauhar I'm not saying
that right it also called the sea of
trees now some paranormal sites Will's
call it the world's most popular suicide
destination which is an exaggeration
it's not really I think actually the
Golden Gate Bridge is probably what's
popular suicide destination and even in
Japan I think more people actually
commit suicide jumping in front of the
trains in Tokyo than they do go into the
forest but an unnerving amount of people
do go into this forest with the express
purpose of committing suicide why that
is I don't know but this forest it's
like right at the base of Mount
Fuji and it's it's like on top of you
know like hardened lava and stuff like
that and apparently like the lava that
it's built is that it grew on is like
really porous so it look absorbs sound
yeah so like when you go out in the
woods cuz it's really thick woods and
stuff like it's super super quiet yeah
right so I don't know if that is I don't
know why this particular thing but
there's even a sign and if you look on
Google you can see pictures of it
there's even a big sign it's written in
Japanese but it's basically telling
people you know your stuff like your
family loves you and think about what
you're doing and stuff like that so what
happened how to get you arvin enough
that they have a sign there telling
people not say another thing is funny is
you know cuz cuz the Japanese in general
are such hardcore city dwellers they're
afraid to go out into the woods and get
lost
I don't know about people but people
don't know this but they'll trail line
and string behind them which is the
weirdest thing and that suicide forest
is filled with all these little strings
going through there yeah I don't
understand it why you know but you know
haven't grown up you know in the United
States when you look at the forest
they're talking about there's no way you
can get lost in that yeah and well it
should be noted too that you know
committing suicide is not the only
reason that people go in there obviously
like a lot of people go in there because
it's really beautiful and it's like a
natural environment they don't like that
things are that's what I mean it's just
people they don't want to get lost I
guess because if you're gonna kill
yourself why would you need to put it
yeah but they showed it yeah well that's
probably people that are maybe they also
go out there and then they change their
mind and they want to be able to go they
want to be able to come back yeah I have
any notes tied to the beginning of the
string maybe that led to where the body
was yeah maybe so they can be found to
be found now and that's not to say they
have like a team and this must be one of
the worst jobs in the world they have a
team that goes through there like pretty
once a year yeah to clean out all the
suicide bodies they can found now the as
far as records have been kept because
the Japanese government won't tell
anybody how many bodies they found
anymore because they don't want to
encourage more people to do it say the
highest number so far was in 2003
and that was a hundred and five bodies
that they found in there over that year
it was about a year's worth yeah and
that was about a year's worth those were
the ones they found um you want to
investigate a haunted place that's
that's the place to yeah well and and
they say that that forest is super like
I don't know if the haunting is like is
like a result or of all the people dying
there or it was call or is calling that
too somehow
yeah so that apparently there's it's
super haunted and there's all these
Japanese because like Yuri I or whatever
they're called and you know they're
calling okay yes we're speaking of which
you guys you have you guys ever seen
that movie the yokai yokai yokai
warriors no Yoga Yoga yokai monsters
that's right
it was a trilogy but the first one was
the best one yeah I have them I have all
three of them that is a crate that I
love that movie might not play yokai
monsters spook warfare at the club for
goth night yeah about the screens you
love it they love it because it's a
passion and thing yeah and actually I
can get up there in the sound booth with
Dimitri yeah and and spin the little
little visual audio visit we had a match
with the music to match it the music's
and make make a little uh what do you
call it thing the umbrella monster dance
yeah yeah it's pretty cool see that yeah
the umbrella monster is the weirdest one
tomato cuz it's like what like I
understand that they have you know
spirits around you know items that were
once expensive and you know it was like
a family heirloom and stuff but the
umbrella Monster has a single foot yeah
a single eye tom and a tongue that hangs
out yeah you can see it on YouTube yeah
put the trivet up on YouTube yeah I
should put a picture everywhere that's a
good name
but yeah it's because the Japanese
believe that the law the Tokugawa era
Japanese so that's you know seventeen
eighteen hundreds runnin time there they
believed that the the longer excuse me
the older an object was the greater the
chances that it could become animated
right soul which isn't that weird really
so that's not that was oil
come to life yeah well the oldest thing
in the average Japanese household back
then was an umbrella because they were
expensive yeah so people kind of had
this underlying fear that maybe one day
the umbrella might come to life and for
some reason have a single eye and have a
sign hanging out well it looks like an
umbrella yeah I guess why the tongue
hanging out though that's the only but
that's the part I don't get I don't get
that anyway but yeah it's a good movie
but yeah we kind of were you know we
were talking about Japanese who was so
forceful like is it yeah you know they
have an average it's easy you know
between 30 and 50 per year they think
they're not really sure like I said they
don't know if they find them all most
common methods are hanging and drug
overdose but I'm sure there's some other
yeah they'll set up a tent out there and
go get it go to the and actually kill
themselves inside the tent - yeah but
you can't be there's some pretty like if
you look cuz when I was doing the when I
was trying to get to all the pictures
for the video for this episode it's like
there's some pretty creepy pictures of
you know all the stuff they found like
all these shoes and these all the shoes
of the people that kill themselves in
here this year and it's just like haha
it's pretty purpose but still less of a
bummer than the case we talked about
that is you know yes it's kind of like
the monkeys in the little pit of despair
like we'll see now that's why I
specifically didn't make that one last
cuz I didn't matter I mean I know
suicide the suicide forest that's not a
super cheerful topic either but I was
like well I definitely don't want to end
on this Sylvia likens case cuz that's
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] right there
but uh oh gosh so we're close yeah we
didn't get we didn't get to talk too
much about the suicide forest but you
guys can look it up it's that right yeah
and there's not a lot to it there's not
a whole lot to it in the movie like I
said the movie the forest in it was that
right I didn't love it and hate it it
was it was passable but other than that
so we're going to wrap up the show with
another shout out to the project
Entertainment Network go to their
patreon page at patreon.com slash
project internet and get this money
supporting all the podcasts there's all
kind of cool stuff on there and
shirts and buttons and whatnot and we
also have t-shirts um five different
designs at zazzle.com /ha a question to
our regulars should we do a movie review
would you guys what you have been
thinking about not like I need any more
work to do but I'm just saying we've
been thinking about doing maybe like the
odd supplemental movie review it would
be an hour long it would probably just
be like 15 minutes or something like
that so you know but we wanted to see if
there's anything that's probably fine
yeah we probably do old movies cuz I
probably something scrap I don't see a
lot of new movies and it's yet it is
more fun to do reviews of like crappy
movies or or hilariously I can't wait to
an alien covenant comes up and I can't
wait til the new Star Wars comes out
yeah I'm very excited about this we're
actually gonna go with the new Blade
Runner yeah that's right we're actually
gonna go to the theater more than once
this year Wow yeah okay so I hope it
goes what yeah all right all right here
here look at me just before I even say
bye he doesn't even say bye he's so rude
bye bye see you guys next week bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you